my thing is sometimes there are people  like a bob larson or others that will  use that fear  as a way to control a congregation and  happen many many times  and i think the question for me is who  are they promoting are they promoting  god are they promoting themselves what  do you think they're promoting  i think oftentimes they're promoting  themselves the great line in the new  testament for anybody that's a christian  and takes their faith seriously and  wants to be a minister the focus is  in reference it says i must decrease and  he must increase so the focus is always  on  god and what god wants to do and i think  when the focus comes on the individual  too much is when the person has crossed  that fine line